thank you for joining us America Cody is
with us in Wichita Kansas hi Cody how
are you hey Dave are you better than I
deserve what's up oh so this is kind of
a long story so I've got to keep it
really short
um back in February I started school and
I tried to go with as little debt as I
cleared a home started listening to your
show so my grandma offered to take over
my finances for me so I turned over my
daughter's cards or got away all of my
extra cash she said she would apply to
toured small school tuition how old are
you I'm 25 and why did you need your
grandmother to handle your finances
she offered and it sounded like a good
deal when she offered to take a role on
I wouldn't let her why is it a good deal
for somebody else to handle your money
um I had hope they should be able to get
me on a better financial track okay at
25 I've been your job I know it is okay
all right so what happened well my
sister got checked her credit and found
that my grandma had opened four credit
cards in her name and with my grandpa
committed suicide and we found out that
leading up to the day he took his life
my grandma had dreamed about $15,000 his
last $15,000 out of his bank account and
she that so I started looking into my
bills and she hadn't paid any of my
bills for several several months and I I
guess I just don't know what to do right
now
okay and so when did your grandpa commit
suicide Oh about three weeks ago oh my
lord son I'm sorry what a horrible thing
so how old is your grandmother seven D
okay well what you need to do as soon as
you get off the phone is you need to
take back control of all your finances
okay before the next hour rings twelve
you have 30 minutes get it done okay if
you have to shut down the checking
account if you have to shut down the
credit cards and if you have to freeze
your credit that's fine but you need to
get control of your finances because
your grandmother for whatever reason is
misbehaving we've established that
correct yeah with your money with your
grandpa's money and with your sisters ID
and for all we know she's opened up
credit cards in your name as well
correct we don't know well I'm not sure
yet okay you need to check your credit
and see if she's done that to you as
well but you need to shut down so did
you give her your checking account as I
what you gave her to take over and how
does she handle her money I gave her my
checking account my debit card just go
down yeah just go down to the bank and
close your checking account just close
it and whatever money's in there use it
to be moved over to a different account
and have that bank tell that bank what's
going on that this lady is you know
she's misbehaving she's a mentally ill
she's a thief we don't know what it is
but we need to get all control taken
away from her is that all she had was
your debit card in your checking account
that's all she had of your money or your
stuff so you get paid it is a direct
deposit into your account okay so you
need to change that as well right to the
new account number today sir today yeah
are you gonna do it today all ongoing
keep okay good and then you just call
her up and say granny I got enrolled in
a financial class and so I'm going to
take over my fine
ANSYS thank you for your help I'll take
it from here and then you need to call
make sure your bills are being paid call
every one of your bills how much debt
have you got my bills totalled I added
it up a minute ago it's right around
2400 how many different creditors do you
owe that's just regular bills oh that's
like utility bills and that kind of
stuff real serious you don't have you
don't have anything you don't have any
debt no okay
okay then you just need to call your
utilities and make sure were they on
auto-draft on your account yeah okay
then you're going to give them your new
account numbers and get all that
switched over today so that you take
over the handling of your money and you
can just let grant another know that you
know with Grandpa's passing I didn't
want you to have to fool with this huh
Nissan won't take it over and I'm
enrolled in a financial class and I'm
gonna get control as a 25 year old man
of my life and lien till I'm sorry she's
actually until right now she's in jail
why is she in jail all my sister pressed
charges for the credit cards in her name
yesterday Wow okay well you can let her
know that you took the bank account over
due to all this weirdness in the family
then very interesting Wow
so people in the family are not real
happy with grandmother right now I'll
take it no yeah very sad sad to be 70
years old in that and so and then the
next thing you need to do is you need to
pull a copy of your credit bureau report
and you can do that for free once a year
with each of the three credit bureaus
and see if there's anything showing up
on your credit bureau report regarding
identity theft roommates if she's open
cards in your name as well okay and let
me help you too
your sister may or may not have been
really mad and she may or may not have
meant for your grandmother to be picked
up but here's the thing the only way if
someone opens an account in your name
the only way to get that account
leered other than pay it yourself which
would be pretty stupid to pay a count
that you didn't open when someone stole
your identity the only way to keep from
doing that is you have to file a police
report and when you're filling out the
police report they always ask you if you
know who stoled your identity and if you
don't tell them that would be breaking
the law and so your sister followed the
law properly when the police report is
being filled out and said yes I know who
the identity thief is my grandmother and
I'm surprised actually that they went
and picked her up but they did and yeah
you know so I'm because it is it is a
federal law it is a federal offense now
to steal an identity and so she's in
trouble she's in real trouble but your
sister could maybe accidentally
activated all of this because she just
had to do a police report to get the
identity theft removed from her name
right but she may have been just mad and
got arrested I don't know either ways
fine with me but um because a woman is
definitely a thief but oh my goodness
what a sad thing though what a horrible
thing you guys are going through now
Cody uh well actually how much do you
make what kind of money do you make
Oh forty thousand a year okay all right
are you really ready to take this over
and learn how to handle money if you are
I'll show you how I'll put you in our
class I'll um see okay but you want to
square your shoulders back now and not
look for anybody else to babysit you
you're too old for a babysitter so time
for you to man up here okay you hold on
I'll have Kelly pick up we'll get you
signed up for Financial Peace University
you can go through the class as our
guest and we'll take good care of you
and show you how to handle money and
then you go handle your money thanks for
calling in Dave hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]